I just have a few words before we start
so let me explain today's protocol I'll
be the Genesis block I'm going to
introduce wrong and then the previous
speaker like yesterday will introduce
the next speaker and not only so the
previous speaker will also make sure the
next speaker didn't go over time if we
call questions from the audience
okay so if you're a speaker remember you
have to stay to the end of the next talk
so can I extend my time and then use the
type of the next speaker actually just
like quick kind such that even if the
co-chair which is me fell asleep in the
middle of the podcast when I came back
alive and continued to participate in
the project everything should still be
continued as now the speaker's today
working for attacks - I didn't sleep
well last night
so today's time is it's black I'm going
to introduce round by telling my Genesis
story with drug which drug does enough
ok so this is how I met Ron in 2004 I
was an interesting idea
research I was interning in the chapter
however was not the photo booth and then
back then I got the first first-year
graduate student I knew absolutely
nothing about crypto I didn't know that
wrong with a big name cryptography and
that's why I was pretty enough to Sandra
an evil and requested a meeting with him
and Rob was very kind that he blacked
out half an hour 2090 and told me about
what he was working on back then it was
the framework at Universal composition
so I didn't know this down what Ron was
talking about but I didn't they remember
that tom was really really passionate
about universal composition so I that's
really like you know I remembered all
these years but what I didn't know back
then was in a few years I would have
tried to switch my research area to
crypto and then in a few more years I
would have found Universal composition
paper like one of my favorite papers in
crypto and the paper is so fascinating
and in the following sense every time I
read it I think I understand it so every
next time I read it again is the
previous time I read it I didn't
understand it so just like the paper was
written over like 91 years you also need
to read it over many many thank you I
just want to say that I'm the same every
time I write either thing can't stand it
yeah yeah thank you
so so this thought comma kind of came
out with discussions with Dalia actually
the in the first workshop of this of
this semester you know there were lots
of discussions about about modeling and
consensus and different things coming
from different directions and then I
thought maybe it's actually good to
actually give some talk about you know
this framework which can maybe help
bring things together because people
hear from many different areas in fact
even more ears that deal with you know
block chains that that somehow
everything has to work together and
anyway so that's a little bit like you
know and you have to be a bit grandiose
when you talk about bitcoins either way
it doesn't work so that's that's why the
title anyway so so I feel it explains
better in a minute so so okay so we we
want to do this public ledger which is
this this amazing things the simplest
thing ever that but it is amazing that
you know we just have this this thing
that keeps records for us it's available
everywhere everybody can access it it
doesn't cheat and it doesn't do stuff
but then it keeps records that come to
it and you know by anybody can put
records there and keeps them in order
and maybe along also with some time of
the registry and there is some publicly
verifiable hopefully simple very
political that you know you you put a
record up on if it's valid but maybe you
don't even need us but it's probably can
be everything goes recorded so this is
like the simplest thing ever but it
really is amazing right because we don't
have it and if we add it over we we want
to be we about building it but once we
have it is doesn't saying don't have it
doesn't come in nature and when it
realized
lots of things to do you know the
central currency is a global 20 commerce
you know a new world order you know
people don't have to form into of
countries in government and you can
people can be things that in principle
the world can be regulated in in a
decentralized way and we can have the
you know cell phone leasing engagements
contracts can even have things with
doesn't have to do with economy you just
you know a global records where global
records registry of everything that
happened history probably documents you
know all the deeds the literature art
science everything is there
as it happens and there's no question of
faked truth not fake truth what happened
which order it's just there and but
wouldn't be amazing to have that in the
world you know same way that we have you
know to the tcp/ip we just have a plug
in to this ledger and we see what
happened one but so and then so this is
a how kind of II get introduced it's
also talking about silver yesterday
about how he gives work so this one I
think his first talk they talked about a
grant a couple years ago and a mighty he
was giving this talk was a beautiful
talk lots of you know aqueducts and and
and then things about the history and
then the end of the you know that was
the last slide of his talk
oh there was charging soldiers and stuff
you know but then the big L not sure it
was this particular one but it was maybe
a nicer picture of a class you know
holding the world and he and and says
thank you atlas we'll take it from here
and that was the end of talking that was
I know the way simply does it and you
know or thinking like you know is this
like overly presumptuous and this but no
it's not and it's really that's what
this is about and can thinking we take
it as a responsibility it's you know
it's a good thing to excite people to
get to work in it but also
responsibility since we are doing
something that should or can or has the
ability to carry the
world on it then we should be
responsible to doing it right right to
make it it actually works sorry yeah but
you know but actually no it's not hubris
it's actually looking the other way you
know if this is what we're trying to do
we better take it seriously right in
some sense right yeah so the the first
impression that you that that I thought
pin when they saw this thing in the talk
yeah it's hubris but after second
thought that's really but anyway anyway
so so so we're trying to construct this
ledger and we have all kinds of
different things and primitives and
animals going around you know so the
things that we like and know and things
that a new things you know the the PKI
and signatures and you know point to
political communication bowel delay oh
and then then Eddie will jump way bound
delay why not just synchronous you know
we could cleaner and and then then and
then we have you know global clocks the
local clocks and information dispersal
in and in partial broadcast and in all
those puzzles and block chains and and
and lead their election of all kinds so
we have all these things and how do we
make them work so we we can talk about
different pieces and different people
talk about these pieces but we actually
want to make it work and so so it really
has this feeling that we kind of like
building a stack of four cards and how
do we make it all work together so like
the you know the big hat in the Hat and
you member that is not alright my friend
this is not all we actually want to
build things on top of the ledger right
so we want to build things on top of the
global ledger we talking about the
central currencies and in this registry
of event in this global library and then
privacy preserving things on top of that
because they want those to be their
privacy and and then smart contracts and
distributive governance and maybe you
wanted to make it like work together
with the law because you know in the end
we have to make things
work with society in law it's all we
want to have the whole thing work
together right and and it's not so easy
because one of those characteristic of
this beast is that is that the reason it
works is actually pretty delicate right
so there are lots of things going on
there and and and it's not that these
are just applications that sit on top of
lower primitives as were used to in fact
the fact that these applications there
they give incentives that actually give
a reason for the security of the scheme
to work into existing begin with and so
we have this kind of like seemingly
intermingled set of concerns and
guarantees and requirements and which
are not so linear as we like because so
much of the technology actually existed
like 30 years ago or 40 years ago of my
30 years ago you know with this the
company of Toth Harbor did this lock
chains and everything but but it didn't
work I didn't fly why some since there
were no incentives right for people to
do it and once the incentives came in
and things started to ramp up so so the
whole thing is it's really kind of like
one big circular mess in some sense and
unless you start to put order but what
we would like is to to break it down is
we like to do with engineers to break it
down for simple models and then analyze
each model separately independently of
everything else mean as much as you can
and then have simple proofs of security
or whatever properties if you want from
it and then you want to be able to
combine those model in natural way and
get this overall so here right so so in
particular you want to build those
Ledger's kind of in a systematic in
layered way as as we know to do and then
maybe we can actually have one day some
standard standardized notion of Ledger's
of components of Ledger's and we could
maybe have this
tcp/ip this another layer to the network
from the caching which is kind of a
legend a layer that everything no that
is built in a layered way and people
just build on top of it without even
thinking how it sees realized right so
and this is really not what is happening
today it what's happening today you see
is those those Ledger's or currencies or
whatever they're built kind of in a
vertical stack way in a self-contained
way and we have this separate stacks of
things built you know all the way from
the from the beginning to the end
independently of each other and which
doesn't really work together and somehow
in order to be able to work together we
need some common interfaces and and
security guarantees and obstructions so
so this is kind of like the the goal
well then how you know how to do it
so it's not that I have concrete you
know new solutions but they've been work
there's been work that has been going on
so let me try to give you the the basics
so so what you want at this university
composable security so what I'm going to
do an office for maybe having you know
some people in the audience it's going
to be a repeat over boring but hopefully
not too much and but I think we're going
to give the high level things I think
there are enough people in the audience
that maybe have not seen a lot of it
before just to give the high level idea
so what's going on okay so somebody say
this Universal cut possible security so
there are lots of you know this is just
a set of ferrets are lots of work in the
crypto community about the finding
security because it's it's important and
it's delicate and it's and it's hard and
different general frameworks and they're
different composition theorems and and
and the UCT are you know it was very
much just evolved as a linguist saying
over the years together with that and
took from many of these and and you know
it's not just a thing standing by itself
but nevermind let me just describe now
the
the basic of the fair warning so you can
have the CEO version of the framework so
we want to analyze security of protocols
so so so first we want the system to to
represent protocols so in a very high
level so there's a protocol which is
this system of individual components we
call the machines interaction so why
meet us a few words about it in a bit
but just think of it whatever way they
interact and and the idea is to think
about this this this protocol of the
system as you know the interfaces
between the system and the external
environment which here is just it just
one single component you just you know
our machine or unit or whatever and
there are two sides of two types of
interfaces one is that the input output
which is a desired interfaces what you
want is an engineer this is the input
this version of the system and this is
the outputs that you you want and this
is kind of like the side effects the
things that you don't really need and
you don't be you know you don't help you
but they're there because the adversary
well there are some people can see
because you know either it's the you
know the leakage from communication or
from you know corruption or parties or
whatever so this is a leakage of
information here and there are also some
influence and going from the system to
your thing the way the adversary
influences your system via delays or
whatever if the adversary influences the
you know the system and the idea of
maybe again behavior crafter parties but
anyway so this is the two types of
interfaces and then you compare the
system to turn a kind of an ideal system
and this is kind of the specification
what you would want your system to look
like and the specification you know as
in as opposed to other ways of writing
specification is a list of requirements
you actually write it as another system
which is your ideal system which is in a
it naturally can think of it as one
machine you don't have to worry about
distribution
assume that they had one machine and
this is all the interface
again all the api's from the external
environment the inputs and corresponding
outputs and here there are also side
effects and here you are writing his
sincerity specification dividing the
side effects that you are willing to
tolerate so what what information it
gives you willing to tolerate from the
city you know to leak from the system to
the adversary to the external parent and
what is the tolerable you know
influences that you are willing to and
this is this is again this is a
specification so ok so sorry what you
want to say again the the first attempt
is to say that the system is secure
or realize the specification if no
environment can tell whether it is
interacting with the system or with the
do specification right so that kind of
like nurses they discuss the
observational equivalents of finger you
know for the distributed people here or
the concurrency people so this is like
the basic requirement you know except
that I kind of like a partition the API
is for you know with side effects and
and ends with ones but this is too
strong right yeah yes
that is I'm excited
a great question I'll pay you later
answer the next slide so yeah so so the
the question was what's the difference
between side effect and and and and and
and whatever API what I call the API is
you know this picture there is no
different yet but the point is that this
picture this their current is too strong
it's way too it's way too strict
we cannot mate Hanscom we cannot realize
it because the thing is that often you
know our system is actually different
than the deal functionality right the
specification some particular the
specification is one machine here are
the many machines so of course this
would look different because you know
environment can tell because you know
just because here the communication
going on between machines there is no so
you know so so so you cannot do it it's
too too too tight so so what you want
you want to actually relax it and when
you relax it this is where exactly where
the difference between the side effects
and the API comes in it comes in because
now burden by I'm going to allow more of
a relaxed notion of to realize energy
system and what I mean I upon adhere a
machine kind of a fudging machine which
I'm going to call a simulator because of
historical crypto reasons and and this
machine now I'm going to say that the
system P realizes in specification F if
there exists you know that's part of the
other list can do or the quality
portable design if you want specialities
to come up with a less such that now
this s sits between the environment and
the specification on the side effect
links and can translate things to each
other right so so that now this is the
requirements there is enough in there
there isn't and simulators such as for
any environment there is no way to
distinguish right and and then okay you
would want you know to put restrictions
on us but
what is the meaning of this so so it's
obviously this is weaker but what is the
meaning of this so so I said so what is
the rationale here's one question so
rational for any yes so you can think of
it that animal many manipulation like
any the P the protocol can do to email
any OSA any leakage of information from
PT and information from PT II could have
done also in the in this ideal process
you know for me in the ideal s
specification by adding s right so any
leakage it may be a better way to say it
any leakage of information that P that
leaked from P tui could have leaked also
I mean that the process by just adding
us right so in particular that would
mean if I go back to the picture that
here this was some you know there was
communication between the parties and
here there is no communication between
the parties that means that now the
simulator will have to generate
something that looks like communication
between the parties to make me think
it's here and has to do it based only on
the information that you get from F
administrative amid the communication
between the parties doesn't make more
information than whatever is allowed
okay so that's the one thing and the
other rationale is just the other way
around again that any side-effects that
II can do to the protocol we are those
side effects railings could be done also
in the to to to the to to the to the
ideal specification F by using yes right
so in the same way as should be able to
take any side effects to any
manipulation that evils to do to P you
should be able to do it also to F again
using the interface if allowed
when you look side effect is okay and
they see already colorful because a lot
of people talk about side effects and it
said maybe ending implementation how
much heat the machine gives you could
model this so this this is a general
framework you can apply it and that's
kind of success the beauty but you can
apply to anything to go out apply to
heat apply the 80222 delays you can
apply to to just information
communication and the combination what
about I mean you can think of it in any
level right so you want to say that the
heat doesn't leak information on the
secrets that would mean that that your
simulator will have to generate kind of
heat signals that will look just like
what the protocol does and when this
simulator knows nothing about the
secrets space of implementation and what
it means that we'll have to specify more
qualitative machine model what I mean by
those errors you know the actual bottle
of execution all goes down to you know
the details
as usual you know this would think this
was taking 20 years but yeah and so the
sorts of attributes that you don't even
want to talk about in the spec I mean
the implementation might have heeded my
head vibration might have
electromagnetic signals sure they don't
want to talk about my spec so one way to
do that is to again it's how do you
write the specification so write the
specification saying you know here are
the things I care about terms of
functionality you know I want to give
this correctly and here are things I
don't care about in terms of releasing
information there are things I'm going
to give the interface I'm going to let
the simulator or whoever asked me
information about things I'm don't worry
about leaking and things that I don't
want to leak I will not tell so if the
sumit ask me you know
features that I don't care about giving
away then I will give away and also if I
don't care about specific aspects of the
functionality I don't care if you know
the if my output has 5 V to 10 bits but
but I don't want it to be less than 5 or
not 1 and 10 then you can say you can
allow that you cannot be simulated to
tell you how long the output use V but
you just put in the limit here so you
get your model how much influence you
allow up to your limits so it all
depends on again the specification the
thing is that your specification should
be written as a program for this to work
which there is another issue is how to
understand specifications because then
it's a program maybe you know it doesn't
mean what you think it means
but that's another issue so anyway so so
so this is actually the basic and this
is and this is the some sense this is it
this is the whole thing and now
everything else is details of up to the
model of of exact deepening down what do
you mean by by communication and the
information moves around etc ok so in by
the way but this means now the
definitions are longer symmetric and
also if the protocol realized
functionality doesn't need the
functionality we're at war at home which
is it's a good thing right you want to
have many different protocols
realization functionality in the same
way that one protocol really can realize
many different functionalities anyway so
so but we call that with their goal was
modularity and also the side doors of
getting security in any in any
environment so so the methodology of
achieving both goals is this composition
operation so so what we take what we
want is this mechanical operation of
composite together
systems of protocol said that they can
on one hand express most natural
position operations that
think about the reality and also
preserve security and here here's the
game in very terms here is the
combination operation so so what you but
you have a suit you have some protocol
at all it's row enjoy it in one box but
you can think of it this way little
thing there he knows this wood protocol
there are many components here they talk
to each other but I put them together
under one box they all say run the same
code and they know they talk to each
other by some way he says there's some
sessionid that combines them both - oh
maybe some other means that I can say
these guys talk to each other one call
them a protocol and this protocol I said
has subroutine to another protocol which
are called fire and what does the mean
see if I have it many different
instances of Phi I mean we could be
could we have one it's in so many
different instances but each one of
those instances also is a distributed
protocol right so I can think of so one
session of of TLS you know secure secure
communication for a powerful thing with
this one session that has a secure
communication that has many key exchange
are subroutines rative key changes once
it's one subroutine inside the secure
communication and each one of those so
then maybe this is the multi pocketing
each one of those has to parties etc but
never mind and the this is the
subroutine that means but if you know
locally within each party which is one
protocol one process that has sub
processes and this process talks to
other processes so so it's a it's
operates the subroutine is is defined
locally and also defined globally and
what I'm doing I'm just saying I'm going
to replace the subroutine of one
protocol with just another protocol we
just replace is just normal summative
replacement substitution with some and
supporting another subroutine
but it's done kind of like in the
diversity distributed way everywhere in
in other parts of the system so that's
operations actually right it's very
simple syntactically
but the idea that really captures
everything that we say because you will
let's see what the theorem it says and
then it captures so so what the theorem
says is that if I have two protocols
that are now I'm thinking the PI such as
pi you know realizes Phi now I'm
sneaking fide not as in a dual
specification but just another protocol
which makes sense if you also talk about
realizing another protocol alright so if
one particle you realize there's another
protocol Phi may or may not be in a deal
specification right then you know for
any protocol row when I replace PI with
with Phi or five with PI I get you know
i get a protocol that realized a few
minutes let me say more clearly I start
with the protocol that that is a row
with 17 holes two instances of Phi I
think with this specification or more
deal protocol and now I replace it well
our calls to the actual implementation
for apple pie and what I get here is
this whole protocol realizes this
protocol okay so if this is again a key
communication protocol and uses ideal
key exchange whatever deal cage keep
stage wins and now I have a kitchen for
a call which I analyzed separately that
the keep stage realizes the the ideal
key exchange then if I plug in the real
key exchange instead of an int exchange
I still get the same thing
security-wise we're both correctness and
security with this definition of before
and this allows for modular design as
you can imagine and this can be done
it's not a thing that you know so there
is we can think about cases that
actually happen in life a lot
fortunately unfortunately that we have
systems when you have many different
protocols that use the same or let me
say the following news before I do that
here this composition theorem is limited
in the sense in the way that I can only
talk about I can only kind of like do
composition for properties they don't
have any joint state urgent information
between them so say here have they have
two instances of a deal key exchange I
can only replace them with two instances
of real key exchange if they are
separate they don't have any underlying
common information however in
specifically key exchange we know that
they don't want to change for holes even
just UUID you need some underlying basic
authentication mechanism poverty
infrastructure right and then we don't
be a lot we don't live in this beautiful
world because our two separate key
exchange protocols actually use the same
public infrastructure and then I cannot
use this off the bat because it doesn't
fit the framework so you have to do
something to make it work even when
those protocols have some common
infrastructure common with everything
else so this is something that it exists
if the protocol realizes there either
this specification with respect to some
some say global long global
infrastructure or functionality then you
can still do this
even with this lower thing and this is
something that that was realized later
tell more stories about it so so so this
is this is kind of reform it and
actually four Ledger's it's important
because we think of a ledger is a one
basic thing that don't use the Winnie
protocol so it's important and also
within the ledger there is a random
Oracle there is a timing all kinds of
things that you want to use think of
them as common resources that they apply
to municipal so we need that a lot
anyway it can be done there of course
limitations and when this works but but
still it works okay another variant that
I want to talk about saying little bit
you know just to say that it exists and
how right so you can also talk about
this thing that why insist on having a
single simulator you can try to make the
definition more refined in the sense
that you can talk about you know cases
where you know the system that the
purple has multiple parties and this for
definite components that are separate
from each other and you want maybe to
have to say that you want your your
interface this simulator to be separate
different one for each component not one
global simulator right so this would
only make sense if if the also the
environment would be speak to that part
if I would be split a bit bad but the
point is that you want to simulate to to
to be split and then kind of think of it
is a local simulator so you don't have
one simulator that has double do of
everything and in a managed to do it
this way but actually it's local
simulators that only control
informational to some party or some
component of the network and if you
manage to show show security with
respect to this a more fine-tuned refine
notion of of simulation then you get
things then you can you can use it to
capture things like you know
several adversarial parties that penalty
don't combine together to one adversary
when they what kind of adversary to each
other they're competing with each other
and each second and they just to say
that this way can actually allow it
doesn't capture things like game
theoretic things like fully implement
stuff yes
also the environment is now okay so you
so so so you know for this first video I
think I missed again awful days it
should be some line here so those things
you know it's not complete they would
communicate but you communicate in the
restricted way to part of the
environment they talk to each other not
in a limited way I mean you don't need
that when you could make the definition
for any environment but then it would be
very hard to realize because you know
you know here the stimulus cannot talk
to each other when but but but I'm
saying that the second the point is the
important point is not so much that
these guys are separate but the
simulators are surface and this will
give you the extra
[Music]
but that would be a weekly requirement
so maybe you want you know you think of
it that you want to have you think about
it in our game or a complete computer
competitive game between two parties and
you think of this game is complicated
and able to say that it just has the
same properties as the simpler game the
same game theoretic properties this
simple game so you want to assure this
notion of simulation to to simplify
things but then if you only talk about
you know one similarity similarity two
things together then use the rules did
the fact that the game it's a game it's
been a cooperative game in order to keep
the milling fulness you have to do the
simplification process separately for
each party for instance yeah one for
each player yes if you want to have one
one one game one you know say two party
companies or whatever five party
cooperative game and you want to say
this actually is the same as navigating
which is simpler assuming something then
this this allows you to do such a thing
yeah there might be some conditions put
on the simulator because otherwise it
seems like anything
I understand yeah yeah so so why so the
point is that you will need to to be
able to simulate a super interesting to
think about the animation should be a
complete example say
you know so so so you are you are doing
a game that involves some digital
signatures right and you want to you
want to say that you don't want to think
about the digital signature product poly
one just to think of an ideal signature
functionality and you want to say let's
just get rid of the crypto and think of
a game as it works with an ideal
signature thing and you say okay now I
place my signature scheme with an ideal
functionality and this is something that
you can do separately because because
you can simulate tipsy you know if you
can do the same placement seperti which
is which in within each party but i can
think of another example of another
simplification but it doesn't make sense
you know by somebody giving you you want
to compete them in you know I want like
the coin to be zero you want the coin to
be one and we can simulate the global
simulated it just chooses completely
there going to be random sure it can it
can choose it but then you lose the
property of the game that you compete
with each other so maybe you can take it
more flying but this is the idea sorry
yeah actually taking more time than I
wanted but anyway so so so just to say
that again
the this that was the idea the
high-level idea but of course the devil
is in the details and you need to figure
out the system you know a system model
that that that you know on the one hand
is simple enough that you can work with
and the other hand it is expressive that
he captures real stuff and you can
capture real concerns right and this is
this is a challenge and there are lots
and lots of things to how to you know
how to do with challenge right and
they're actually different frameworks
they do it in different in different
ways and in the one the layers of
fabric.you wants a programming language
the stuff you want to have some slightly
scale of a favicon how do you how do you
build those things so so the way to talk
ad you know so what are they kind of
like
main sticking points about how to matrix
in concrete so so there is the issue of
you know are you talking about what are
the models the models are you know are
you modeling programs algorithms are you
modeling actually specific systems
implementation processes and we want as
Croesus computer scientist to to model
algorithms and say I'll go through as
many associations and there's the run
time versus the Dean of the code and
assume you have to worry about this and
then you have talked about you know how
to define the actual model scope of
computation what are the dividual units
and again you want to look in a way that
you can use it to do many different
things from heat to to overall systems
service units communicate and generate
messages how they are addressing each
other how do they know identities of
each other and and how is the execution
done you know is this kind of easier
parallelism how the parallelism
addressed etc so so and then how to
define content protocol so there's
there's a lot of subtleties and
different ways to choose one way or
another and you mo need to make sense
and again you want to capture attacks
and and and and physical parts new
currency physical time stuff like that
and of course bounded computation
bounded resource operation assumptions
etc so so so all the things need to be
done so the you know currently the
system that you know the look at the
paper to there two frameworks actually
so there is a simple one which much more
basic the fixed number of entities fixed
the connectivity nothing dynamic nothing
changes over time but they but again
explicit each actually get the ideas
it's relatively simple by the complete
framework we can actually work with but
if you want to do something more
generous then there is this other rest
of the paper that actually talks about
it tries to model things in the most
general way to capture all the
constraints that we've been talking
about and so this is what it is when I
think it's where now it's pretty stable
ready and
and the point is that okay so the issue
of whether this to do this global stuff
with global subroutines whether you need
a separate framework for that or not you
know historically the world there were
separate versions the framework to deal
with that but now we can actually do it
all within do you see don't need to
change anything which is actually nice
for modeling point of view and and but
the point is one thing to say is that to
keep things simple so so the underlying
execution model is actually sequential
and deterministic and very simple so all
this
none of this concurrency
non-deterministic scheduling etcetera
that it doesn't work with crypto anyway
but you don't need it because you can
express everything in other ways
essentially you know you know the
components get activated one but once it
functionally in passed up into each
other etc whatever way you can see the
model everything and there's a lot of of
work in the formal modeling work about
about how to do parallelism in non
determinism and stuff and just somehow
we don't need it and and it also
interferes with yeah
time's up I know it doesn't need to be
many purpose you can but the reason I
say just simply to think about Taiwan
but of course this pie can be you can
think of pie itself to be many different
pie eyes in some sense just for
simplicity of notation of thinking yeah
but yeah yeah so yeah yeah I know yeah
okay so yeah okay so so okay so lots of
things never mind and the point is that
okay so in total of what thank you
anyway just to say that that the today
with this going back to to to what we're
doing here what we here for
so so the thing is today with with the
today's Q two currencies and blockchains
in ledgers in fact we are doing
something very different than what we've
done traditionally so you know I miss
lots of names in differences with their
people doing trying to kind of model the
the world in the UC or whatever way in
this new world and so now we've done no
longer point-to-point communication we
don't think of an authentication as the
basically primitive and and then the
notion of synchrony and you know it's
very interesting that you've been doing
kind of don't apply anymore
so instead there are different
primitives that people define and just
build things this way so there is this
the gossip network that again the you
know identification in authentic you
know authenticated communication in the
traditional sense know PKI because you
know you can't and so so they said there
are other things that's called the
gossip network which is a basic
primitive you know and then you assume
some boundary
the communication the ever and immoral
you have these signatures without PGI
and on top of that you can build you
know you know those two things that
we've been talking about time we
actually two different ways to get
ledgers one is this this longest chain
protocol aka Bitcoin site stuff and how
to get block change that working from
these Ledger's and authorities we can do
this take place to live their election
or proof of stake based protocols and
again you can have another way to get
the signature almost a similar jury with
different small differences and then you
can combine it with this incentive
compatible morning to give rationale and
then you get the centralized currencies
and as you get even the centrist cash
meaning Z cash with all the the
Decrypter of the heavyweight crypto of
of general snarks built into it to get
the van and imita for cash but all those
things can be done mod early so either
things that are published or in the
works and I know of are doing this so so
this is it and just to say nothing that
in touch but I think it is important to
touch and I think if there is anything
that can do it is I think it's something
like like like the you see which is how
to deal with smart contracts and how to
program will model them and how to top
things about higher level stuff like
human intent and things that have to do
with the law and society like like how
do you capture contingencies they can't
expect like things that you have to do
in normal contracts right and and and
they talk about the ability of a
contract and what happens you know there
is a flood and you whatever so so how to
capture those things and then how to
encode them and be compatible with the
law and somehow have an interface
language with in between you know with
what we do and the law and and this
ideal functionality seems to be
something that could be done that you
realize technically in one hand and the
other hand its language that can be used
to
the break okay so
[Music]